all right we're hoping there's audio
this time anyway hello once again
welcome to Android design and action
I'm your host Roman Nurik because what
he pays out of gosh and hi my name is
Nick butcher all right so uh so today's
episode is going to be a route
presenting images we're going to share a
bunch of tips and tricks on on how to
present kind of images in a delightful
way inside your apps a lot of the things
that we'll talk about today have been
covered in past episodes but we felt
that it was good to have kind of a recap
episode as well as talk about some minor
new things not necessarily new and
Android but kind of new things you
should be thinking about when related to
kind of showing photos and thumbnails
inside your apps so without further ado
should we get started and let's Nick you
want to introduce the design principle
yeah absolutely and the images are such
an important part of your user interface
that they're explicitly called out in
androids design principles which say and
that pictures are faster than words and
that you should use them to get people's
attention and be more efficient and so
there's you know a much quicker way to
express your information in your user
interface by using imagery if you have a
screen full of images versus a screen
full of kind of text and labels and so
forth one is going to be instantly a lot
quicker to kind of understand to kind of
drop what's going on and then the other
so you should really make you some
weight cap and the other thing I think
it's very important to about this kind
of principle is that a lot of these
kinds of vices out there these days
phones and tablets and so forth have a
really kind of beautiful high high
resolution screens so it's a real missed
opportunity not to provide really
beautiful crisp imagery where you can to
enrich your user interfaces to actually
push on yep and so one of the most
important things when thinking about
using imagery in your application is
bearing in mind that designing for
Android is designing the scale designing
for variety of devices out there and so
what that means is when you're thinking
about your images you think about how
they're going to play a user interface
you need to build in a level of
flexibility in there so that your your
user interface can work on a variety of
different screen sizes and shapes and
then your imagery can stand up to that
and then still look good so this is a
technique that we've covered a couple of
times in the show so I'll go quite
quickly over it and but wanted technique
that works very well is to kind of
respect the aspect ratio of the image
you want to show but to be a little bit
more flexible about the exact balance in
which you show and one way you can do
this is using a center of crop technique
so what this will do is and depending on
how much space you have available to
show the image it will kind of blow it
up or on crop off the sides or so forth
in order to maintain the aspect ratio
but to kind of fit in the amount of
space available to the image it's a very
important technique to kind of embrace
and I think as we've said before this
technique works really really well if
you have kind of images which don't have
a particular focal point so for example
you have this picture of some bacon
which we always seem to come back to you
here on Atia and then it works
particularly well for this kind of
content you have people's faces you
might risk kind of cropping off
something you might consider the focal
point of the of the picture so just bear
that in mind
cool true move on yeah so so and yeah
going next that we're going to talk
about different ways that you can kind
of like decorate or kind of change the
imagery which you're looking at and the
first thing we're going to write here is
using different masks so Android has a
kind of a particular look and feel and
when it comes to shapes so for example
you don't see many kind of cool shapes
or rounded rectangle shapes but what you
will see is lots of simple geometric
shapes like squares circles and so forth
and eyeballs maybe but one technique you
can use with your images in order to
kind of like break out of a rhythm and
make them pop or in order to kind of set
them up and out of your content somehow
is using a different kind of and
decorations like a circular mask in this
instance in order to kind of make it
stand out the nice thing about the mask
for Avatar photos too is that it's you
know it's a bit softer I guess in
general circles are a bit softer than
than squares or the things like that and
they kind of it's kind of nice to unify
or to tie this this visual element the
circle to the idea of a person right so
not necessarily circles it could be
other things but kind of making sure
that throughout your app anytime you
show a type of single type of object if
there's visual consistency and using a
circle mask is one of the ways in which
to you can achieve that I guess yeah
definitely and moving on here is an
example from the path application which
combines that idea of using a circle
mask we're providing kind of a slight
white border and a drop shadow onto it
just in order to I think set it apart
from the content give a little bit of
kind of and content protection because
if you're not sure what the color of an
image is going to be if it's
user-provided you can probe you can stop
that from contrasting with your
background elements for example and make
it stand out as well giving a little bit
of visual depth yeah should we move on
to text overlays all right so um so
anytime you show images and actually
this is something that we'll talk about
in a bit with full bleed imagery but
basically anytime you show images and
you want to show captions next to those
images you know there's a couple ways to
do that right so first of all you could
obviously you know you could have the
photo and you can show captions below it
if you have the space but one of the one
of the ways in which you can kind of
maximize the use of space maximize the
also I guess maximize the effectiveness
of the photo or of the image is to make
the image take up as much space as
possible and overlay any sort of
metadata or or titles or captions or
things like that on top of the image so
here's just a couple of examples of of
that in action I guess so this is from
the a dia app the Android design and
action app from Andreas and you can see
that you know the images take up as much
space as possible there aren't you know
big white gaps in between them and then
you know having text inside those gaps
this is purely kind of you know letting
the image take up as much space as
possible and using the space on top of
the image as the as a space for the
metadata
so here's another example this is the
Circa app the circuit app is a is a
recently update or recently published
news app and here you know they also
have the the news article take up the
full or the the news thumbnail take up
almost you know half the entire screen
maybe even a little more and then the
title is just kind of an overlay and
here just a couple of other examples
from from google play music and the
people out but the you know the reason
we wanted to point these out is that you
know these are a couple of different
examples but they each user use a
different form of background protection
and background protection is basically
the idea that you know if you just
overlay text of whichever color black
white whatever if you just overlay text
over an image very frequently the image
itself is going to contrast too highly
with the text and the text won't be very
readable won't be very legible so
background protection is is something
that you place in the background or some
effect that you provide that makes the
text legible so here's an example in the
in the Atia app there's a kind of a dark
a black drop or a black gradient that's
a very very common form here in the top
right there's the people app and instead
of a gradient they just use kind of a
you know a a semi-transparent
black rectangle that's another common
way of doing things and then here in the
in the Google Play Music app the action
bar is also you know it's using a
gradient for background protection and
so whatever the background is whatever
this photo is even if it's just pure
white you'll still be able to read the
the title here and see the controls so
the one thing I didn't want to talk
about is the way circuit does it is
actually very interesting it does a
combination of a slight drop shadow on
the text which it alone is you know is
usually enough to make it legible but it
also applies this blurring effect and
you know the actual execution here I
think could be a little better there
could be kind of a faded blur or
something like that it's quite a sharp
edge between the blurred and not blurred
image but the idea is that they're
blurring the background to provide as
much contrast on the text so anytime you
see edges for example you know in this
photo you have a turtle and you know
that that hard edge between the photo
between a turtle in the hand that's
actually visual distraction
now in this case when you're just
focusing on the image that's that's good
thing right you want to focus on the
different details in the image but here
where you just want kind of a kind of a
more vague sense of the image but you
really want to focus on the text they
kind of blur out the background make
those edges much much blurrier and make
the text much easier to read so a couple
of different ways to to overlay text or
overlay metadata on top of your photos
to maximize the amount of space
dedicated to two images another great
aspect of using these kind of overlay
labels is that it lets you and kind of
say this whole item is the interface
it's kind of the idea of putting your
content first and then anything anything
else is kind of within its contained
within it so it's like saying on the
people app on the example where you have
a calling a contact now this is the
thing that you can click on this is the
person this is the data item I can
interact with and there isn't another
label off slightly similar to the size
you have to kind of expand out the area
like I click on a fourth it or whatever
it might be it's completely contained so
this overlay label helps you to kind of
fill this kind of and data centric kind
of UI yeah it's really the image is the
touch target right and it's it's almost
like if you look at you know modern UI
is versus past you eyes really the
content is the chrome the content is the
is the interactive target and you know
here when you let the image kind of when
you let the image be the target I think
that you end up with a much more rich UI
so okay sure you move on move on to full
bleed so this falls this is kind of
related to two text overlays and kind of
in a similar manner we have some similar
screenshots but here the idea is that
you know you want to so we keep hearing
I am noises in art okay anyway um so you
know here the ideas that you want the
image to take as much physical you know
space as possible you want it as much
real estate as possible you want to you
want your UI basically to be as
immersive as possible so here's an
example of that where basically rather
than having the the image start at the
bottom of the action bar
maybe kind of pushing the rest of this
content down in google play music they
actually say decided that hey why can't
the image be part of the action bar so
here they use kind of a translucent
action bar with again that background
protection and let the image go as high
up as possible and so here's basically
the concept of maximum space for content
maximum space for images when you have
multiple images like in the case of
thumbnails what that means is you want
to minimize the gaps between images you
want to minimize the space between them
and so here's again an example of the
people app where the space between each
image is only about one or two dips and
and the idea here is that if you had if
you had larger space you had larger gaps
whether they be white or black it would
be extra visual distraction it would be
kind of yeah it would it would
potentially you know help further the
visual hierarchy but the hierarchy here
is well-established already and so extra
space there would be just kind of static
you know static space that's not being
used that's that's not really kind of
committed you know really assisting in
presenting this content so I think that
you know the the fact that there are
small gaps here I think is you know it
services the content really well and
then too quick other examples here's
another example of a Flipboard again
with very minimal space between photos
between the thumbnails and then here's
another example of going completely full
bleed we're basically the entire the
entire screen is a photo it's not a
static photo this is kind of an
important distinction to make it's not
just a static photo that is the same for
you know every time you launch the app
it is a piece of content it's still very
very dynamic so the idea is here is that
they spent as much space as possible
showing the the content and then
overlaid things on top of it in a you
know in a background protected kind of
way the you know the app branding as
well as some of the kind of things that
you can look at once you've opened
magazine so that's full bleed imagery
sure you move on to touch feedback yeah
so touch feedback if you've been
watching our other episodes we tend to
mention this quite frequently and that's
one of the reasons for that is we
actually see many apps that don't
actually implement touch feedback
one of those one of the areas where
people often forget is image touch
targets or touch targets that are made
made up largely of images and so one of
the one of the I guess one of the
problems with them with touch feedback
where the touch target is largely made
up of an image is that you can't really
engage the touch that the the touch
feedback on the background like you
normally could we say text or something
like that so if it touchable areas that
are largely made up with an image you
should really use a sort of semi
transparent overlay that covers the full
touchable area in terms of like the
color that you should use it should
really match well with whatever your
sort of highlight color is or your
accent color is for your application and
the focused and check state should
really be about 50% of the press state
in terms of opacity so actually let's
just jump across here and quickly look
at some examples so the two on the left
is sort of no nose you can see the very
left example here oops it's highlighting
the background and I actually increase
the borders a little bit here so you
could even see it but so to the points
that Roman was talking about just before
the full bleed imagery and the text
overlays often you won't even have any
background to highlight in these cases
so that's that's just not really going
to work where the image makes up the
majority of the touch target the second
no-no example here is is not having any
transparency so not only does this not
look that great but you can actually see
sort of the content yet that you're
touching behind and here's an example of
just sort of a good way to do a touch
feedback on a particular image
another couple of examples the press
state and Czech state and actually this
is a little tricky to see here simply
because the opacity is you know it's
it's kind of a it's fifty percent but
it's let's see if we can zoom in a bit
you can see it's quite it's slightly
darker here than it is here but it's
it's a little tricky to see so here's a
few good examples of touch feedback
where you know where the where the image
is the majority of the touch targets so
on the left here we have google play
moves on the left here we have google
play music and you can see here they're
highlighting the entire card and they're
also using the accent color the sort of
orange accent color that sort of matches
with google play music the second
example here is a goo in Google Play the
App Store itself and this is one of the
collections the beautiful apps
collections so you can see here the
cards are actually larger and again the
entire card is being highlighted here to
indicate the touchable region and you
can see here the the text is not
overlaid the description of the
applications actually falls below the
main image but the entire touch target
is being highlighted and then the last
example here is the Google i/o 2013
application and you can see the avatars
that we were talking about before with
the rounded circle and in this case just
the circle of the images being
highlighted and as you were saying
before I think this is an excellent
opportunity to kind of really embed your
branding in there so I think Google Play
Music is doing a great job there with
them you know extending his orange
branding into the touch touch States you
know holo design language is in no way
prescriptive about color and you should
really see this as an opportunity to
play the break away from that default
holo blue and really kind of bring your
own branding to the table yeah
definitely actually move on to focus
yeah absolutely so what images are
beautiful and great for grabbing
attention sometimes that's not exactly
what you want and you want to be able to
emphasize other information or kind of
mute that M information somehow so some
some good example doing that and we've
picked out to showcase today the first
one here is from the currents app and
Google app for kind of reading news
feeds so on the Left we can see there's
a news feed we've done nice big
beautiful pictures and kind of the title
and strapline and so on but once you've
actually read that story and you kind of
come back up to this true story that
isn't quite interesting they actually
completely grayscale and the image and
they mute the text as well so it's kind
of it fades away visually because I've
kind of processed that I don't need to
go back to that it makes it really easy
to pick up where you left off or see
what you've read while you have it read
something this is a great example of
having both visual images and then like
subduing them when you want them to not
grab the attention so much and just a
second example just for just to show you
versatility is actually when I was
taking a screenshot of the parents app I
noticed that the screenshot notification
in their vision buds is the same thing
and so the notification bar you're going
to be rubbing shoulders with all kinds
of different content most of it going to
be presented by the system it's going to
have a uniform look and feel so if you
were to use kind of a full bleed like
very colorful image they might look
really out of place and they might kind
of be quite jarring experience it might
not look like a notification so they do
a nice job of desaturating me and the
image there so that you can and you know
it fits in better mode surroundings and
you can focus on what's important which
is have the touch target and the
secondary action to chair hey drew move
on for the next one yeah a slight
variation on this is combining that kind
of tea saturation with the touch
feedback that Adam was talking about and
sometimes if you just apply a kind of
semi-transparent and I like over the top
of an image you can get unexpected
results with colors bleeding through and
so forth especially if it's kind of user
generated content you don't know what's
going to be and to apply slightly more
control to this you can actually combine
these techniques and untouched
desaturate out the image and then over
or touch and touch feedback to give a
slightly more control the parents so in
this example I didn't include the
natural state maps they measure half
like grades these yellows but we're
going to mute those colors and just
applied the touch targets have a
slightly more control effect yes I think
you know with Google Play Music is
another example orange doesn't really
you know overlay well with some other
colors so you know desaturating and then
applying the orange almost like applying
a I think it's a hue a hue layer in
Photoshop just kind of manually changing
the hue of every color you know in the
image they can kind of make it a more
even look to the photo and the next
example of providing focus in the
application is and using blur effects so
similar to the circular example you saw
earlier and I think this is a Yahoo web
application which and it's kind of
trying to run into mostly in the same
screen so on the first screen it wants
to give as much prominence as beautiful
imagery which is sources from Flickr
right showing just how rainy London is
but then when you want to show more
information on screen when you scroll up
to show you know the forecast and so
forth and you want to mute that
information so they do a great job
they're applying the blur effect that
kind of really realized content shades
so the content is not prominent rather
than the imagery so a great technique
yep
sure we might agree the last the last
kind of focus technique we want to talk
about it's just really applying an
dimming effect so you can use this to
great effects is to kind of you know
show show an imagery and then as you
scroll some text over topic in this
example from Grand Street then just
applies this kind of fade mask on top of
it in order to give some background
protection to the text and bring the
text to the forefront of the attention
as well and this to be really simply
achieved for developers just by setting
the kind of the same flag one image all
right
Potato Head all right so let's talk a
little bit about placeholders so I think
most apps actually do get this right for
the most part but any image that loads
in your UI that that has any sort of
load time any
time at all should really have some sort
of place over there I was playing with
an app the other day that had no
placeholders and I was just blindly
scrolling through a list not knowing
what was happening so it really gives a
good visual indication to the user that
something is going to load there once it
gets around to loading ideally you
should try and tailor the placeholder to
the final image if you can if you have
any sort of additional information about
the image maybe the dimensions the
colors things like that anything like a
low res cached version of its cache
version and I'll show you a couple
examples on the next slides about that
and then finally when the image actually
finishes loading a sort of subtle
animation to transition to the final
image is definitely recommended normally
that just means a fade in or a crossfade
you could do something a little more
fancy but I would just urge you not to
go to fancy really this should be quite
subtle yeah and then on the development
side you should just make sure that that
image that animation doesn't run every
time the ListView scrolls up and down
getting kicked out Nick now you know the
way that the ListView works it does
recycle views so you've got to make sure
that the animation isn't running
constantly every time that the ListView
is scrolling up and down so let's have a
look at some examples quickly so this is
the Google Play app again and you can
see here and it's actually hard to get
these screenshots because they doesn't
load pretty quickly I had to go into
aeroplane mode but um because of the
sort of card based UI of Google Play you
don't even need sort of an additional
placeholder image here the sort of cards
and already conveys that something is
going to load it in that space so it's a
pretty nice example of sort of baking it
into the existing UI this is the system
gallery application and it's kind of
hard to notice here but actually they
use the dimensions of the image that
will load to sort of show that I guess
'sir makes having some room issues
okay so Nikhil join will rejoin us
against Shirley was I saying yes so as I
said it's kind of hard to see here but
the dimensions of the placeholder image
actually match the dimensions of the
final image so if you haven't get a long
panorama or something it'll be thinner
and if you have a sort of portrait photo
it'll be taller it's almost kind of like
you know at an airport when an airplane
is landing someone's like the landing
strip for the airplane it means it's
kind of guiding it or it's not really
guiding the airplane well in that case
guiding the airplane but here is guiding
the user like it's saying the thing that
will load will be here it's almost like
the helipad okay yeah obviously it's not
always possible to do this but you know
where you can we have the extra
information it's definitely a nice
enhancement seems like Nicky's joined
again that right back there is there is
so that and then this place for example
we really like it's the pinterest
application and I'm actually not sure
exactly what they're doing it looks like
some sort of I guess average of the
colors in the in the final image to load
or something along those lines anyway
but not only do they show the sort of
dimensions of the image here in the
placeholder but they also approximate
the color of the image that's going to
eventually load so again was kind of
hard to get these screenshots and you'll
see the scroll is a little offset from
each other but you can see here that the
image is sort of roughly match up across
these two screenshots oops yeah it's
great I mean like all this is one extra
database field right just one extra
database field that's computer that you
know at on the server side it just says
you know take the image maybe average
the pixels in some way and and store
that hex color in this database row and
you know with that you get this massive
improvement in the experience okay and
Nick is gone again this taken all right
we'll just keep moving on and hopefully
you can join us again so the next topic
is full screen galleries so you know the
biggest advice here is you should really
be using a lights-out mode which and
then hiding the system UI any sort of
app you are you may have and the action
bar all at the same time generally
that's engaged in sort of one of two
ways not only tapping anywhere on the
screen will will sort of engage
lights-out mode and then tapping again
will bring back all of the chrome and
then normally there's a timeout of some
sort as well like maybe three four or
five seconds of inactivity of the user
not touching anything and the chrome
also just fade-out lights out lights out
mode will be engaged the other thing you
should always make sure to do is support
the standard gestures so pinch open and
close to zoom in and out
keep moving boobs Nick yeah I think cuz
we're running late yeah that's what
happens when we do shows live yeah yeah
and then double touching to zoom in and
zoom out again you should always use the
standard sort of paging physics as well
as the standard over scroll glow that
appears when you reach the edge of a
gallery and then I guess on the
development side that normally means
just using the standard view pager class
from the support library for photos
there's a class called photo view by
Chris Bane's who's on our team based in
London that you can also use on the
development side the last point is
really in this particular case touch
feedback is not really required simply
because the entire screen is really the
touch target it does really make sense
to highlight the entire screen and also
the the UI really responds will respond
instantly to the users touch anyway
because the you know the the lights out
will be engaged and disengaged
immediately any other comments guys one
of my bug bears on this is a people who
don't implement that kind of the pinch
physics right so like things like when
you have two fingers down you know doing
a pinch you should still be able to pan
around
so I want to say he's one of these
standard libraries like for any of you
because they do it all right
then can I have to write UX yeah and
actually I'll talk at the very end when
we talk about graphs I'll share a piece
of sample code that actually helps to do
that at all a quick very quick sample of
lights a blood going Oh fingers and
actually a bit of Inception here we can
show the gallery engaging and
disengaging lights up mode here right
now with the slides that were using and
on the development side there's actually
a template that you can use called full
screen activity that is part of Android
studio and is it still part of its
partners nope still part of Eclipse you
know you can actually go and create all
the code that will get the exact right
behavior for engaging the full screen
view and then the last thing I wanted to
quickly mention is transition animations
so this is an example from tumblr and if
you're viewing a posts in screen on the
left and then you tap on one of the
images that image will actually zoom out
to be full screen and then when you tap
it actually zooms back again and this is
quite nicely you're not sort of breaking
the users flow on the development side
there's there is a classic unix called
activity options this is mostly useful
though when moving between activities
rather than staying within the same
activity but it canceled help you help
assist you build that animation between
say a grid of photos transitioning to a
full-screen view of gallery photos and
if you want to do this not between
activities but between different views
for the developers out there there's
actually a training class developer
danger comm slash training one of the
training classes on animation
specifically shows you how to do these
kind of zoom zoom ups and zoom outs
animations
alright alright so I think we were super
low on time so I'm going to quickly just
jump into a bonus topic which is graphs
so graphs aren't really you know images
they're really more interactive images
if you will but we wanted to show a
couple of quick examples of graphs done
right the first first I want to mention
that in general you know these are going
to be interactive graphs so it's almost
like an interactive image so I think the
anytime you look at interactivity or
zooming or anything like that
the gallery app the system gallery app
is generally a very good example that so
you see you know multiple fingers going
on double-touch works and so on so I
just want to show a couple quick
examples of graphs and use as you can't
see that so the first is this
interactive chart demo and this is
available as a in the Android training
classes so here you'll notice that you
know you could do the same thing you can
with a full screen photo view you could
zoom you can double touch to zoom in and
then the other nice thing is that you
get edge effects right so if you're
looking to do something like a graph or
basically an interactive information
based image of some kind this is kind of
a good starting point another quick
example is the quotes app and we've
covered this one before it's by a
developer Michael Pardo I think there's
the publisher name is slightly different
but if you look at one of the graphs
they actually do things a little
differently they have this kind of this
zoom bar or whatever you want to call it
I guess and they have these little
handles you'll notice that these handles
are actually using the same visuals as
text selection handles on Android so
it's very very clear what they do I
think they're actually inverted you
should probably facing the opposite
direction but it is still kind of cool
that you can kind of do this and then as
you touch and scroll across you see you
know specific the specific values of
those points so again those are just two
quick examples if you want to take a
look at the sample code for developers
for how to do that interactive chart
thing here's the code there it is
alright so with that we quickly want to
do a shout-out to Mike Denny who is just
joined the Android developer relations
team as an
Android design advocate of Mountain View
welcome Mike
he'll probably be joining us on future
episodes of Android design in action and
yeah I think this is probably a link to
his announcement post on Google+ but
yeah please all welcome Mike alright I
think that's it for our episode after a
rough start as always I'm your host
Roman Nurik see you guys Adam quash bye
from Nick butcher
bye bye from Nick butcher across three
different conference rooms that right
yeah you had a little tour of the Google
London offices today thanks for staying
with me nice see you guys see you guys
next time